[Music]
it's really just a real opportunity to
be physically somewhere learning from
experts asking questions and just
getting smarter about what's happening
in the business unless you know
everything about what you're trying to
do you should show up have the
conversations meet lots of new people
it's been pretty fun
next 2023 is unmatched I mean look at it
all of this around me it's been awesome
to meet the developer community in
person so many people I've met online
before it's been awesome
it is so amazing to be back in person
here in San Francisco I've had the
opportunity to connect with a ton of
customers and colleagues the Keynotes
were amazing the blue sessions they've
been they've been pretty amazing
[Music]
I'm here at Cloud next it has been great
to see so many people in person that I'm
only emailed with or seen on video
conference in the last year and plan out
what we're doing in the coming year I've
also learned so much it's been great to
see everybody next year in person as
well
it's a wrap next 2023 is unmatched
oh my God next 2024 is right around the
corner